[Music]
hey everybody
me again talking about creepy books
horror books
this is my tomes of terror show so let's
get into it
so this book was another recommendation
that kept coming up on my goodreads kept
coming up on like various channels i was
watching
and this is also a new york times
notable book i believe
the hardback came out in 2012 and then
the paperback came out 2013
but i am just now getting around to
reading it and i'm just now getting
around to hearing about this guy
i will definitely be reading more of his
stuff i'm saying right now this is
called
the devil in silver by victor lavalle
now from what i can determine victor
lavalle is a writing professor at
columbia
and he has also written several novels i
believe his wife is also a novelist and
is also a teacher at columbia
they both teach writing as far as i know
also i think they have a son named
geronimo which i
just thought that was very funny so i
thought i would mention it so this book
as i said is the first one of his that i
read now it is
marketed as a horror thriller which
i guess it sort of is but this is kind
of another one that is sort of
genreless i want to say now if you just
want like a very rough approximation of
like what the tone of this book is like
or kind of what this book is like
here's kind of the elevator pitch okay
imagine
one flew over the cuckoo's nest meets
bubba hotep
okay and then you kind of get the gist
of like where this is coming from
also got a little bit of a um maybe a
christopher moore
kind of vibe although not a zany a
little bit of a chuck palaniuk or
however you pronounce his last name
um a little bit of that kind of vibe too
it's almost like
it's like a dark comedy sort of
it's like a satire like a social
commentary but it's also like really
funny and then it also has like a lot of
horror elements like a monster type of
uh story
and uh toward the end particularly it
gets like pretty gory
so but it's a really really interesting
like a really interesting character
piece
it's just like a really really good book
and i just like enjoyed the hell
out of this book it took me a while
because i started reading it and then
like i had
a whole bunch of other projects usually
i don't like to like leave that big a
gap
but i definitely like picked it back up
and then just like read the whole
like second half of the book maybe even
more than half like i read the whole
second half of the book like in a day or
something like that just because i was
like so
into it and like so invested and wanted
to see where it was going and what was
gonna happen
so basically the setup is this
there is a guy named it's not his real
name but um he's called pepper
do they even say what his real name is i
think his real name's peter but they
only mention it a couple of times
so pepper is kind of this um
this kind of working class white dude
he's like he works for a moving company
and he has like uh some anger issues
he's basically a good dude
but he's just like real hot-headed and
he has like a tendency to kind of like
go off and beat the crap out of people
like when maybe he shouldn't
so at the beginning of the book i guess
this woman that he had sort of been
dating or wanted to date or something
like that was having problems with her
ex-boyfriend
so pepper gets it into his head that
he's gonna help her out by like beating
the crap out of the ex-boyfriend
at like a bar i think it was and then
like some other dudes come and then he
beats them up too but these other dudes
it turns out unfortunately for him
are undercover cops so
what ends up happening to poor pepper is
that he gets taken to the police station
but it's like it's the middle of the
night at some hour or something
and uh this is set in new york like
right in and around queens new york
so i guess there's some i don't know if
this is a real law or not it wouldn't
shock me if it was
but i guess the cops kind of have this
workaround
where look we we arrested him like right
before we were going off shift it's like
we don't want to do the paperwork we
don't want to deal with it
so let's take him to this place called
new hide which is like a mental hospital
and then we can just like put him there
they put him there for observation for
72 hours he'll be out of our hair we
don't have to worry about it
so that's basically what they do
so pepper gets taken to this
mental hospital and
the scary thing that happens is that and
he's not
he's not crazy i mean the whole thing is
pretty much it's in like the third
person
and every now and then it kind of like
dips into other people's like thoughts
and perceptions as well
but for pretty much the whole book
you're with pepper and you're seeing
things through his perspective although
it does
you know occasionally go into other
people's perspective as well
but the cool thing about pepper is just
see he's a very even though he
does like some monumentally stupid
things and things you're just sitting
there going oh man it's like you're
gonna get in so much trouble
but he's such a likable like
big galoot type of guy that you just
can't help but sort of be like
you know he just seems like that type of
dude he's just like this likable schlub
kind of um and he's kind of like a big
dude but you know like a big dumb guy
kind of
so he gets taken there he gets he goes
to the uh
intake with the doctor and everything
and then like the doctor is like well
you know the law says that you have to
be here for 72 hours of observation and
if we determine
that you need some kind of help that we
can provide you
then you will be in essentially
incarcerated here
until you know we deem you fit to like
release you
now he kind of like starts arguing and
fighting and stuff like that because
that's kind of his nature he's very
you know rebellious he doesn't like to
be told what to do um
but it ends up that because he's being
such a problem
they essentially drug him and by the
time he wakes up
the 72-hour time period has passed
and now he's essentially a patient at
this mental hospital
and he doesn't really have a lot of way
of getting out like he doesn't really
have much family on the outside or he's
kind of estranged from them
um he doesn't have any money it's like
they you know they kind of took all his
stuff
so he's kind of um hosed you know
basically
so as it goes on you um he starts to
meet some of the other people
in the uh in the mental hospital and i
think that's kind of like
one of the strengths of this book is
like all the characters
are because the pretty much the entire
thing as far as i realize the entire
thing is set
in this mental hospital so it's kind of
a long book it's like 400 something
pages
so you almost feel like you're trapped
there with him or like incarcerated in
there like with these people which i
think is like really really effective
because you don't get to see anything
else you don't get to see anything
outside
of what is going on it's just very very
insular and they're all kind of like
trapped here
but one of the big strengths of this
novel is
the the characters like the way that
they're drawn and the way he
interacts with them the way he slowly i
mean because at first he feels like i'm
an outsider i don't belong here like
what are all these
crazy people you know that kind of thing
like probably like most people would
react but the thing is it's like as he
gets to know them
he's like well maybe you know they're
not i mean some of them do have
like problems and stuff and some of them
probably should
be in a mental hospital but they are
still like really
very humanized they're all very
sympathetic so it's not kind of a case
where
you know some of the characters are kind
of like oh that's the crazy one or
anything like that
so while all this is going on like he
kind of befriends like this old woman
that lives there and she's been there
for like years and years and years her
name is dory
um and she's kind of like the friendly
one that comes and greets everybody and
gives them a tour
now while she's giving them a tour she
says
that at the end of this one hallway
is this silver door and no one is
allowed
to go close to it like none of the
patients are allowed to go even down
that hall or like all the
guards and nurses and stuff like that
will flip out and will like come and get
you
and as it goes on and like now like i
said
i think that the uh you know the
description of this book
uh says what it is that's going on in
there but if you don't want to know
anything
anything about this book then probably
don't watch the don't like watch this
review because
as i said before i'm not going to spoil
anything i'm not going to spoil the end
i'm not going to spoil any big plot
points or anything like that
but i am going to like talk about what
happens like the plot of the book a
little
bit and if you don't want to know
anything about that then
just turn off and go read the book and
then come back so it turns out
that behind this silver door
is the devil i mean not
the literal devil but it's a dude
or it looks like like an old man except
he has a huge
bison head like not like a mask but like
an actual bison head
and so this guy is kind of like he
crawls around in the ceilings and like
he comes out
into people's rooms at night like
through the you know acoustical tiles or
whatever
and he comes down in there and like
supposedly kills some of the patients
so everyone is terrified of him and um
you know pepper starts calling him the
devil like when he sees him
and uh his other friend there who's like
a 19 year old
african-american girl whose name is
lucci that's short for lucretia
um and she calls him the devil as well
like you know so they think that
there's the literal devil living in
there and the weird thing about it is
that
it's kind of like left i don't think
it's left ambiguous because everybody
sees the devil even the people that work
there
but they have like a weird perception
where they obviously
see this patient as they call him
but they don't like let on that anything
is weird about him even though he has a
giant bison head
so you're kind of like are the patients
just seeing him like that or are the is
the um
you know the people that work at the
hospital are they just like pretending
that he doesn't look like that or does
he really look like that
so that's kind of a whole thing too
that's where i was getting the bubba
hotep vibe
because this is very much you know a
bunch of people that are kind of like
confined in this hospital and are
basically having to like pull together
to fight a monster
who they perceive as like killing other
patients
and so like i said as the story goes on
and pepper starts to kind of
get over his initial thing it's like all
these crazy people and he actually
starts like forming friendships
with some of the other people there and
they decide that
that some of them are just gonna like
pull together and they're gonna like try
and fight this monster try to figure out
what's going on and why uh you know why
the staff
like seem to protect this monster even
though he seems to be like creeping into
people's rooms and
essentially killing them or making them
disappear because some people disappear
and they don't know where they went
i mean that's kind of all i want to say
about it because this goes off in like
some really interesting
directions and i will say like
i know a lot of the reviews that i've
done i've called them like literary
horror which i guess this is as well
um this could very easily be an a really
entertaining
literary novel about like a satirical
black comedy type of novel
about a mental hospital in the vein of
one flew over the cuckoo's nest even
without like the monster element
but i think the monster element like
adds something really interesting to it
because it kind of just has that
you know that that added horror element
which i think brings a lot to
you know what he's trying to say with
this book because i mean obviously
and the book it's cool because he's
obviously making a statement about
how how shitty we treat people with uh
mental problems
he's also making kind of um a lot of
statements about it's almost cut it
almost kind of like kafka-esque or
almost kind of like a terry gilliam
movie
where he's talking about you know these
institutions that are like these big
massive institutions that only work
for you know that seem to us like it
seems like this you know
impenetrable bureaucracy but it works
for people at the top so they just keep
it working but it doesn't work for
anybody else
so he's obviously making a lot of
statements about that because you know
he talks about this mental hospital and
how they just kind of throw people to
forget about them and then
you know the way that it operates is
just so
stupid and like so backwards like the
computer they have is like from even
though i'm pretty sure this is set in
the modern day because everyone has cell
phones and everything
but the computer that they have is like
some old thing from like the 80s or some
[ __ ] like that
and it has like this program on it that
you know isn't even
for like what it's what they're supposed
to be using it for and none of the staff
can figure out how to use it and they're
all just like really frustrated
and they just have these big things you
know just big piles of like uh you know
files and stuff that they're supposed to
be inputting but they can't figure out
how to do it because
it doesn't work right so there's kind of
a lot of that going on so it's almost
like an absurdist
kind of um condemnation of like this
bureaucratic
um you know red tape of like all these
people get put in this hospital like
they never get out and it's like
no one cares if they disappear and all
this other kind of stuff
so there's a lot of that in there but
it's not it's not heavy-handed this is
still this is a really
really entertaining novel i mean it's
really entertaining just the way it's
written it's just so
it's so funny it's like all the
characters are just so
lovable you know what i mean this is a
very humanistic uh
novel in the sense that you know you
really feel
you know empathy toward all these people
who like i said some of them have some
kind of severe like mental problems and
everything but
he doesn't ever paint any of them as
other he doesn't ever
he's just you know even the ones that
are like more unlikable like there's an
old guy in there
mr mack who's kind of like an unlikable
dude and like everyone else in the
hospital is kind of like
oh this [ __ ] you know what i mean but
even he is still kind of likable in his
way
so i really admire that he took so much
time
in like you know painting these really
flawed but really like complicated
characters that you can really like
root for and it's just it's just really
really well done and i think that is
really goes a long way toward what makes
this novel like such
a rich experience to read and then just
adding like the fun stuff
of you know the the monster on top of
like and trying to figure out like what
this monster is and like if it's really
there or what it really looks like
you know this is kind of ragtag group of
mental patients that get together to
like try and fight this
monster with that they think is the
devil i mean i had a really good time
reading this and um
i'll definitely be uh seeking out some
more of his stuff in the future
now i think as i said this came out in
2012 initially
i will say i really like because i saw
the um
the person that reviewed it i saw the
hardback cover
and i was like okay like after i read
the book i was like i don't understand
like why that hardcover looks the way it
does
this cover is much more because see it
looks it has a bison hat on it so
you know that's much more indicative of
what the story is about
i also read too that he had written
a novella which might be ebook only i'm
not sure if it's print or not
which is almost kind of like i can't
remember the name of it but it's um
it's almost like a prequel from what i
understand of
uh lucci one of the main characters in
this who's actually probably the second
or third most important character to
pepper um and she
because you know she kind of like
befriends him later on she's not in it a
lot at the beginning but she gets like
more important as the time goes on
so i think that he wrote a novella like
a companion piece to this book
that was almost kind of like i think
it's like her backstory or something
that happened to her when she was a
teenager
like or a younger teenager because she's
still a teenager in this so
i'll definitely be reading that because
i really really liked her character a
lot
and i think that'll like add a lot to
the narrative of this
but yeah definitely if you like anything
literary if you like i mean
if me saying one flew over the cuckoo's
nest meets
bubba hotep if that like intrigued you
then you will probably really dig this
it's writ
it's written in a really i don't want to
say breezy because that sounds like
dismissive but
it's it's written in like a really
readable way it's like really funny
there's like lots of
like author asides but not in a you know
not in a snarky he
you know wink wink kind of way it's
almost just kind of like part of the
narrative and it's just like the way
it's written
and i just really really liked the way
it was written it was like a really easy
read
and the characterization is just is
really good it's like everybody in this
is like so
you know uh just drawn really uh
yeah and like a really complex way and
like all the characters are really
really likable and you can really like
get behind their
their goal and like what's going on even
when they do something shitty like you
can understand why they did it
so it's just a really really great book
and um so
definitely even though it's not i
wouldn't call it like
horror horror you know what i mean but
it does definitely have horror elements
it's kind of almost more like a horror
like a black comedy type of thing
more like i said it's kind of more like
terry gilliam me movie or
something like that so if that sounds
like something that you would like
then you will probably really really
like this because i had a blast reading
it
so uh definitely definitely recommend it
and uh that'll do it for
this book review and i'll see you in the
next one bye